all right and we are lads welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 58
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back from PAX East at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day somebody got they Michael
returning PAX East impressions the
impact of Dark Souls ps5 in the next
console generation God of War reviews
inside Xbox and backward compatibility
to discuss so we're gonna get right into
it so let's introduce the four horsemen
of gaming don't usual suspects at the
round table
my co-host with the Co most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the how of the young wolf
mommy
Lord addict are you going sir pretty
good I do want to state that a kid
smooth is no longer the blood-borne King
I in the blood beat the expansion I beat
the expansion that everyone claimed I
couldn't touch every boss it was they're
removing the post they're all you can't
beat this one you can't beat the next
one awesome this people much that was
like you will never beat this dude and I
literally had people join right after I
beat it's like oh man II beat it
difficult game Conqueror we don't get
into that of course we had our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Thomas
mister offline profile Illuminati
himself my man Lord sovereign how you
doing done good man glad to be back man
had a week off yes last week mad it was
this weird it was really without
yeah let me say man I have a big I'm
gonna bend the knee to you guys you guys
did an absolutely fantastic job at packs
man that's the moment I saw your first
video I was tight that I was not there
with you guys like you know I know you
guys are hard on yourselves about little
technical issues with not but you guys
did an absolutely amazing job and I
apologize for not being there to help
like really like you guys good kill
death definitely know first of all thank
you cuz it was definitely fun a lot of
work definitely fun but up definitely
missed like there's no doubt like
they're so here
we gotta make it happen though you're
there but you definitely gotta get you
back in the fall for the next pax that's
gotta go down it was fun it was
definitely fun and of course we got the
Incredible Hulk earnest aka the XS gamer
the Lord of combat sports was a man of
his convictions the man's nothing less
than the premium experience and is to
get money gamer oh beloved Lord King how
you doing sir I'm doing terrible I got a
head cold that is insane Oh Boston kilt
me like yo we was in packs and um we got
like deep beside the convention hall we
move and we shake it but we said um yo
all right let's get ready to wrap things
up cuz we it was like the first day of
something like that and it was a little
kid smooth when I saw we walking up and
it's snow a t-shirt shout out tonight
Lord t-shirt ah so you know it just it
took us by storm
I think that was the moment the sickness
kicked in Boston was like welcome back
King you're sick gonna take that with
you when you leave
and it was just yo one day I was under
the rope so bad for like Roy Jones just
like my both my feet right now shout out
the mucinex I on one with P Co for that
mucinex um yo let's get to these fights
because Louise impacts Lord Cognito we
trial or cockney who tried as hard as
man shout out to kognito man he tried
his hardest to get me in to watch a
fight and these pubs I told you boys is
like a up about five minutes before you
left
he's like I'm out but it was good fights
right so I had to watch me play now you
had the the which we call it the the
Laura heard fight estee lauder st
landing Laura vs. Jarrod heard that
unification bout now that was about that
you saw a bigger man versus a skilled
Cuban fighter okay let me tell you it
was 12 rounds of the movable object
versus irresistible force on that day
both men one of the names to be heard
and their names will be down in the
fight history books
Laura sticking and moving hitting and
bopping snapping the jab and it was
beautiful to see the Cuban style being
represented in this manner but at the
same time juror was not he was like the
juggernaut and in the ninth round saw
Laura's face he just said man what can I
do to stop this dude it was really he
didn't have an answer in the knife round
but he came out at Efron he had the
strength of a god and he was going at it
but in the 12th round
gerrae her hit him with a short left
hook while he counts the right hand and
drop them he got up to answer the call
but if that was what took away his belt
at the end
by one point it was a great fight if
y'all go see it go check it out on
Showtime Showtime is putting out these
fights this year but on to the UFC with
my girl GI Jane young busy she got busy
I gotta give this the low Cognito
because I'm just a fan watching UFC but
not a fan of this little girl shout to
make the main event was absolutely
spectacular
we had a Dustin Poirier versus was it
just engaging I can't pronounce his name
that was a war I mean to be honest I
don't even know how Dustin career his
legs is gonna survive at the leg kicks
that he was taking I don't know how he's
gonna be able to function in the walk
but I'm gonna tell you right now man
yeah it was it was an amazing fight um
caught he caught oh boy like see like
third or fourth round whoever it was and
he it was a new type of Boogaloo it was
a delayed book it was the Boogaloo where
you thought you was in it but your body
was like did like it's like one of his
legs gave out it was weak because his
body was all right with just one legs
was like no stuff so yeah shout-out to
him though he put up a game effort
you got definitely got the lightweight
division is gonna be crazy he wants a
title shot with Kobe you know I'm saying
after that and you gotta make an
argument for him because Khan is not
around
Ferguson's days about theatrics können
knows how to get his name out it you
know saying so I don't know if it's a
ploy I obviously we know with some real
beef because his little man's got
cornered by curbs people khabees people
ran down on his little man's is UFC
partner do and lo division was like yeah
what now he was talking that high you
know exact they rolled up on so this was
supposed to be the retaliation Icona
throughout the goal he sent out the
Irish goons
whatever they surrounded the bus now you
know come on you hurt another fighters
you're doing all this other craziness I
can't condone that I'm saying so I don't
know where his head's at he got to do
that time you know he's gonna get sued
so he's blowing all this money away I
don't know where his head's at
I know he tries to get his name on I
heard he just got to misdemeanors now
right right night was it was reckless
endangerment of people that was involved
and it's a misdemeanor and it got
dropped down to a lesser charge and it's
not the fact that you know he got time
that he's gonna do because it's gonna be
time served and it's gonna pay a heavy
fine he's gonna get sued but the problem
is is that this honestly yeah he was
like because why I mean I will say this
Connor is definitely I mean khabib his
style that a a grappling
ground-and-pound puts you on the ground
style that is you know the Kryptonite
men he's not gonna do what he did what I
came to he's not gonna and test his
mettle against Ryan he's not doing that
Ryan's going to take him down and turn
his face into Swiss cheese and Swiss
exactly and on top of that let's be real
Connors Achilles heel has always been
running around you know something now I
will say this though three
Kabhi versus Alec what is the king to
his chin game he leave his head open yes
head up when he backs and boxing his
trash right that's why that's why the
warrior fight is interesting because
he's decide if he doesn't if he decides
hey let me test my mettle against this
guy standing up it could be a problem
for Ray's boxing is excellent he gets
hit a lot but his boxing is excellent
but if he oh man if he's decided to do
that yeah it could be night-night it
could be night-night
it'll be night-night yeah man I mean so
that's pretty much what it was just
shots an undercard rest in peace time I
made the veteran Carlos Condit man yeah
and I remember he was one of the top
guys a born killer baby man Oliver he
had that boy doing the choke books he
had a bit of choke it was it was a wrap
your horse all the better that's good
guy so I think real quickly what King
was alluding to when he passed it over
to you was was UFC 223 last week rose
namajunas vs. Rose Doug Rose I love the
truth I love I love a cold blooded
motionless face you know no you might
shook yes
no she's so stoic yes it was just an
absolute understanding of what she was
going to do in that fight and better
Joanna hood what's better in this fight
me just got that much better yeah it was
just one of those things where it's like
I think it's a wrap Emmy Joanna nice all
different was all make a mass Saturday
face did you see her face up no the only
time I've seen a boxers face look like
that was George Foreman when he fought
oh I forgot this dual name but his face
looked like a Halloween mask I looked at
her face and my heart sank at the end I
said man somebody should have loved this
kid more stupid
wait did you allow somebody face to get
mangled in such a fashion
this little killer and she didn't stop
he is like she was enjoying every part
of the face yeah UFC was lit man we got
we got some preludes from set up some
things going on you know saying shout
outs at 1000 GS it took some ELLs I got
said Condit and they got the kid the
other bulge
he took a hard one the young boy arm
what's his name wonder they tried says
the new John Jones in the middleweight
division is real whatever he fought
three round wasn't nothing to too
impressive
you don't say he kind of got through so
I want to see more from him as he goes
up in competition because they really
hyping this kid up but that's what we
got on the combat sports front listening
when I'm supposed to contribute and of
course we have this shinobi gaming ninja
versus germ cell floor Cognito
spreading every onus in the realm of the
ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so let's
get right into what the Lords have been
playing obviously we know Lord addict
has been playing blood-borne you know
I'm saying the DLC anything else have
you been touching this week uh not
really that they took a lot of my time
yeah I thought one more I have the
optional boss um that I have to kill
he's like a weird dude like you take
half his health and he just like his
whole lower abdomen just gets completely
erased and he's crawling at you and like
lavas spurring behind him you can't go
to the left of him you can't go to the
right okay go behind him and I was like
yeah I'm gonna have to get ready for IOP
I don't got time for this
now whatever you play this week so this
week basically nothing man the only
thing I said was fire up that um fire up
the red dead in 4k crispy crispy the
absolute best way to play that game now
this planet is with an Xbox 1x19 it's
absolutely amazing anybody was not
played Red Dead please leave it open I
threw it on I was like yeah and I seed
Howard the DLC is even better
oh the undead nightmare is fantastic
yeah one of the best DLCs ever dropped
for anything it's so complete is
fantastic um so that was it for this
week last week while you guys were aware
of packs I was able to play a little bit
of more Far Cry that game yes I don't
care anything about the the story and
people get mad because it was supposed
to say something political and they
didn't I don't care as far cry day they
know you know how to make a open-world
murder simulator and that's what daddy
that's the and and that that is
fantastic
I will say this that game has no chill
whatsoever it is beef in the streets all
time if you walk on the road be prepared
for beef at all times
like any time I have to go for me to be
I take the scenic route through the
woods
I'd rather get attacked by a puma or
whatever because if you take the road
it's right okay you walk on the road
right though one of the trucks that
belongs to the coal drive by two or
three guys and it they'll attack you
right if you don't kill all of them
quickly one of them gonna set off a
flare and that's gonna bring in the
reinforcements come you have a couple of
guys on a TV con then you get air
support then you get guys dropping bombs
on you from above it's not a small
militia
these guys are and iterated all levels
of government
it's Oh crazy crazy stuff so then at the
end of all that if you happen to survive
mm-hmm you're gonna get attacked by like
a puma or bear they're gonna oh wait
what's going on in the street let's go
and this is every encounter so that game
it's crazy is really fun forget about
all that other stories of stories
whatever in the game fantastic and I did
pick up the bad dudes finally for the
switch and the star does a funny thing
[Applause]
translate well to divided error
experience that for shin then people get
a hold of this Shenmue just like Lord oh
we got it
oh no I do it few games that I feel like
have survived the amount of time that
it's been out if you've been out for
more than 15 years and you go back you
have you then nostalgia it's not
nostalgia glasses that that has took
over your body you've been nostalgia
possess look King have you been playing
alright so you know I played absolutely
nothing always at PAX I was trying to
play my switch I brought my switch with
me
but listen walking around twelve hours a
day on your feet constantly doing this
and the third and then in Boston you
know you got to walk to any place
because you know they always let me
shout out today garbage situation I'm
into premium you got you know yo you saw
you put over X and they bring up a
beat-up minivan Wow yo-yo spending $35
on a beat-up minivan I'm afraid of this
something has to be stopped and I'm
gonna talk to the mayor
little bomb town that that can't be
that's not the way I don't
that's not the way did you know I didn't
like their kid you not like when that
when that minivan pulled up we was like
yo like that can't be in a pasture so K
that isn't it so it's there it turns out
that it turned around and his shoulder
right beside us and D looked at us
serious Bo I need another one see ya
it was that was absolutely hard anyway
so I really want to play my switch I
brought my switch in Yas imma get all
these little merry old balloons now
didn't happen alright so um got back
here and I played my division 4k update
mm-hmm
same shout-out to Ubisoft for never
giving up on not one game think they're
gonna make you love to made a girlfriend
that you didn't really want but then we
gotta he's working really hard like she
doing dishes she's cooking she's
cleaning she's watching she's doing
everything baby you need to told us
she's gonna win your heart and I'm
telling you right now Ubisoft shut up
man shut up is the division looking for
Kate I have to admit combine the
wildlands today um you know I was on my
puppy had to get down with the team the
squad we was getting it on um also I I
put on the for tonight because they said
something about insta tower thing but um
no they wasn't ready yet or something um
just sinister was saying I put on what's
that uh destiny - mm-hmm what the gold
fast past I was an old system oh yeah
yeah it should go faster the trash go
fast anytime you feel that your answer
to anything is the speed to game up you
lost you know you know this is real
Ray's not real ray
yeah we just just shout out the bounces
we literally just had the discussion you
just talked about and oh no doubt that's
what's up and it's like that's what we
said we said in order to get King back
in order to get a dick back you know
it's real rates because at the end of
the day you can show this great
animation and picture images of the
Worman dlc but back in your head you
know you're going back the department to
see that just disconnects you because
it's really not related right so yeah
trust me we know what you say then we
gonna be they handle it really does it
like makes the expansion's like
worthless it's like I'm gonna do the the
core thing and then like nothing else I
do is gonna be relative to what we're
playing exactly and they've got to get
out and we've we had a discussion about
it
weeping honestly I want to anybody this
but it's got to be a lazy design choice
because raids or must be very difficult
let's be real let's give them some
credit Ray's must be very difficult to
create so what they said is let's make
these small little hub raids not a
unified together
you don't saying but at the end of the
day the community doesn't like it it
doesn't like no one's talking about the
last you don't even know the name of the
last ball so what you never saying what
it was doing so they've got to get that
listen the flashpoint 11 is out your
iron law podcast channel please check it
out we go in there Charlotte among many
boxes we really go hard on it you know
I'm saying it as far as that but yes
also shout-out to Ubisoft like you were
saying King cuz um they really I like
the fact that they really even if they
gain flops that what are their joints
like they go back they really spend the
time they listen to the community and
they you know it reinvents itself so
good to say I got a plate of wildlands
because I was looking at a video of it
cuz I was curious because
needed to pray the predator thing and
they're doing like little things to pull
you back in to get your curiosity poppin
and the game doesn't look bad at all
okay I mean they're working out here and
that's what we asked for right so I just
looked that boss I killed at the end of
blood-borne only 9.4% people have that
trophy oh wow a lot of a lot of people
said that that that um expansion was
hard as hell considerably harder than
the main game so difficult game
conquerors in the belly not exactly as
far as me same thing with king man I've
literally had absolutely no time to play
nothing sir bags I had no time to play
that's which did not get you came back
didn't get just like that got a new work
schedule working two more hours a day
didn't get chance plane and without row
some water whose check about a tizz and
guys a good article to thank you
someone's there
you know now shout out to the lore
editor for making me look good out here
in these streets he knows who he is but
I'm yeah man so that's pretty much it
let's get into the poll last week poll
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question with the recent
releases of PlayStation exclusives no
man's sky hell-blade etc now coming to
the Xbox platform does this now give you
extra incentive to pick up these titles
the winner at 64% pretty much cruising
to victory to three-way ILP poll was the
yes only if they are X enhanced group
was the nah been there done that on the
ps4 fam group the shallow third place at
9% only if we get so many bigger ps4
exclusives for me it depends on the game
man like like with hell-blade like I
wasn't even gonna pick it up and then um
Kai was like I can get Nate nothing okay
fine cuz I know I'm the one to put the
money up for the the PlayStation 1 so I
was like you know I love the game I
played it and I wanna support I was like
I got other things to purchase right now
I'm not you went ahead and did it but
again I that's one
that makes sense I know they had
something going like if they reach X
amount of sales in the first couple of
weeks or something they were absolutely
loving helper to merge nose here Milan
looking real good in the realm I'm
seeing
listen pre-orders for the other churches
about to go up we're going to have seven
colorways nine ideas gonna be some new
design things going down let's go baby
boy they're trying to diversify yes sir
that's right so we got a new IO peephole
cooking up a tender show please stay
tuned it's gonna be a very controversial
one so please stay tuned for that so
let's get right into it on these topics
so let's get hot off the presses leave
it was a Saturday night I believe it was
a Friday night it was Friday night
and I'm sitting there and Sega of
America brought out a tweet and I
couldn't believe it was actually my man
Lord sovereign it hit me first and he
sent me the IGN article and it said
Shenmue 1 & 2 he mastered coming to Xbox
come into place these coming to PC and I
lost it Twitter went crazy
send Shenmue saved was what hashtagging
out here you're saying it was there was
tears of joy attic was crying with me -
it was real emotional out here we
thought this day would never happen it's
being released so right now we
is gonna be a specific graphical
enhancements that weren't detail
publisher said that objects gonna be the
definitive version for each game part
one and two fully scalable resolution
and what I thought was real cool is
players will have the choice between
modern and classic controls so I guess
they want to get away from the tanking
Resident Evil stuff I guess and maybe
have two modern controls and for me the
most important feature as well as
original Japanese or English voiceovers
because what I saw the trailer that Sega
put up and Rio is you're like no and I
said yeah so now it's out here let's
bring it to the r2 the round table
she'll move one and two the returned HD
what do we think and then also where
does this sit for us Shenmue 3 so I'm
gonna actually bring it to no an addict
first no motional ties to disfranchise
laughs at old men rejoicing in the
street how do you feel about this
announcement I mean I don't really have
any kind of opinion on it I mean I
understand the hype from it it's pretty
much the equivalent when they renounce
that Final Fantasy 7 was being remade so
I it's something that you play when
you're younger and when it comes out
regardless how much it's aged it's still
wanna play how many times I bought
Resident Evil 7 a lot no but I don't
even Ford a lot I guess I'm curious for
you because you literally have no
connections to this so seeing this is
does it it'll at least interest you in
the lead it just looks like the poor
man's fate would mean last question I
got for addict is on with this release
and specifically on the Xbox side
because that's a point of contention
right now because obviously no Shenmue 3
from right now we know ps4 exclusive and
PC so um do we feel this may work out
positively for Xbox in terms of symmetry
it just depends if it actually sells I
mean if it comes out in just fives and
they're definitely not gonna bring out a
port for 30 mmm interesting I mean I I
put it on Xbox fans if you want that
game you better support this or its fact
which means you an ID asleep that's all
you guys is it maybe if it's reasonably
priced I'll buy just for the support for
nine plain now we did hear that Shenmue
1 & 2 shouts a small wave is a $30 that
surprised me it's all there for both for
both that it what's up we got to do a
history lesson what's up that hurts box
but how much yeah it was pretty much
gets in fights I just beat one of the
hardest experiences on consoles right
now sure these are limiting in a way
they could get on your nerves and again
if they don't fix some of the timing on
that stuff cuz again did those games
come with their change whatever you like
it's one of those games were on fighting
the mechanics worn on fight in the game
too was cleaned up a little bit for the
first one mmm you like tank controls you
gonna get some tank controls exactly so
let's bring it over
Louis ah blood King shed mu returned
what was your reactions out here your
dreams far too like
for me this year like with Shenmue
coming back getting my red dead finally
no just it to me it's one of those
things where they they starting to
listen about you know bringing back
these old properties that we haven't
seen for a while hopefully getting a
splinter cell game that's what I'm
hoping all this sand fish the talk is
leading to getting splinter cell that's
my hardest well so I you know I hope
that's what it is um in terms of Shenmue
the only thing disappointed me a little
bit about the announcement is that it's
not really a full remaster like not
there the upgrading you know resolutions
and stuff like that making it widescreen
but I don't know that we're getting like
it's not getting that high school
widescreen
I mean is it nice to turn to translate
the assets over upscaling them you know
to now yeah fine
if people's clamor for let's make a
quick buck off for this um we can change
a couple of things on it mmm me
personally I'm going to get it just out
of support faculty am I going to play it
probably not um because it's not
something that I could say that I was
looking forward to I was something that
I expected a long time ago right
the noise got probably so definite in
Sega's office that they said we can
actually turn a buck on this probably be
digital only two so at that price point
yeah it's gonna sell at that price point
um I always meant that Shenmue 3 was
coming to Xbox anyway it's not
officially confirmed but it looks like I
mean the tea leaves seem to be leaning
your way but yeah my gut tells me it's
probably a similar situation to how you
know no man Scott helped like things you
know it may be like that period of
exclusivity because we do know the
publisher I believe it was a Deep Silver
sorcerer they're the ones who actually I
believe are going to UM publish it I
believe and then THQ Nordic owns them
now they now own them so and they've
been you know working across like a news
yo TC noir because out here you know me
in these streets so on that
definitely bodes well for shinu's
futures watch cross-platform and I will
say this like King was seen it's like
you know it's one of those things that
they put these that you put this out as
you know to get the fever out why do
people up shenmue yada yada yeah you got
part one you got part two and then you
can go right into the sequel but you
know like we were saying it it makes no
sense from the Xbox perspective to give
them 1 & 2 and not 3 I mean they're
gonna do that to Kingdom Hearts I'm
listen now me break down to Kingdom
Hearts thing for me oh Lord what what's
the deal with that they're getting
they're getting also wanted to another
three we're getting three but not one
and two okay so you get in the later
version but you're not getting the older
version yep and then scoring the March 3
didn't sell on let me see at that time
PlayStation own pretty much the majority
of stock in Square Enix so you'll never
see any of those games at that time
frame come out for Xbox that's why you
didn't see Final Fantasy 10 come up for
Xbox or 12 regardless I mean there's a
lot of games that over a period of time
if it's owned by a certain company or
distributed by that company absolutely
but yeah like shot to the chat right now
they go crazy shot at the punch to the
native go ahead unless Sorento here's a
date y'all for the people who obviously
don't get it they look at him like he's
oh oh geez getting all height for this
[ __ ] stay like shenmue's plays and
we've talked about it knows you on LP
shamil's place is prior to it existing
it is the father of the open-world RPG
and it reference to that graphically for
what it's time for what it was doing was
outstanding
including having different game systems
in it so you got a fighting game inside
the game you had QTEs
inside the game and like I said you had
this open-world cinematic with all these
tremendous dialogue all these great
characters so for it to finally come
back which people thought at this point
you know we were getting to that point
like these things not happening no cut a
shout-out to Dreamcast guy he put out a
video on
yesterday apparently there was one
remastered that someone else did on
their own during the 360 and ps3 era and
Sega did not green light left it so just
to see it come back is a good sign
also to see it get ready right before
3:00 you know this is a good sign it was
just good to see the fields out there
it's taking kids out there wrapping you
know I'm saying wanting to see this
thing you know come back without like
the full remaster absolutely you know
I'm saying
yeah remasters are better I'll be I will
say that when it's something that you're
passionate about you want the full
treatment so I will say that we'll see
what happens I will address that because
they that was the question like okay
you're using the base tech from those
eight at games or whatever and they say
that it's it's considerably improved
upon that so the emulation is supposed
to be much better so hopefully it is on
par with what Nintendo is doing because
that's that's the goal right oh no that
is gonna you know be as hot as one of
the you know uh Nintendo mini an NES
SNES mini but I mean it has an audience
if it's coming from them yeah and it's a
good product
yeah quick before we move on what do you
guys think I was I was catching my mice
which gay they were they feelings about
this announcement they were like no
switch not getting it eighties remasters
no I think feel like the switch again
should be used to not getting games Oh
yes we know that is that you gave it
gains navigator let their bodies it's a
mom actually getting the Dark Souls
that's coming up you know we talk about
any topic I think it's just I mean they
got a they got a budget for it and and
we're just doing yeah you would think
it's it'd be a no-brainer to put it on
there maybe you get an announcement
later but it kind of doesn't make any
sense not to put these games these games
are not so intense that they can't run
on the switch so I don't understand it
are you gonna have it on you are
supported by you just said you're not
gonna play it and all likelihood right
in the same goes for me if it's on my
switch I'll touch it if I buy it on the
Xbox I'll look at it once and then the
indie games are packs being ported
switch yes I did set up and as you
trying to explain to the king adding no
no no I know I know for a fact I was
down bear witness to it you know I'm
them in these people they are rocking
and a lot of those games that exactly
fit on a switch I like new experiences
okay on my switch um I want to control
new stuff I'm gonna have fun like that
messenger game mmm buy it yeah but it's
like you calling out the Shenmue stuff
that's nice if it's seven dollars okay
you know they in dollars I don't what
about choices why can't people have
choice no choice by the world all the
trace in the world but why do we have
Jimmy what I don't understand why why
can't I have it on the system that I
know I would play what I hear when you
guys say I want to buy it because that's
the only the console played on I hear
you try to justify reasons for buying a
switch and you would only play these
games on the switch if you won't even
play it on a better graphical fidelity
brand-new triple-a stuff on that and I
don't have so you can't put you can't
play this on that like oh why is it
after you switch ball to the side it
would fault it was all to decide it
would fall to the wayside and it nice
not to say and I'm the dumbass who buy
it twice [ __ ] the chat is listening to
Kate about that up with a degenerate
with a tee way the Lord's have returned
we turn from PAX East our very first PAX
East and man we got a lot to talk about
so we want to bring it to the round
table obviously
you can watch from afar I'm gonna get
into interview mode I'm just gonna
interview you get your radio bradwood up
so people that support the switch like
that can't interview me I'm speaking I'm
deaf you was talking to yeah no yeah
we're going to tell them how y'all
really fit last time I checked those
dads that you will be talking to they
making an Xbox and you know what to
switch only thing the switch has been
doing for me like waiting is winning MPD
is getting sacrificed getting Center
sacrifice Redemption delay because of
that word only thing we doing for you so
fax he says if I have the month of
return for the round and man it was
definitely definitely an experience what
we gonna bring it over to Lord addict
since he's all feisty this morning what
was his wit just experiencing I'll eat
on the packs in compared to agree just
packs in general what was some standout
thing for you so tell the people about
the packs experience well you know the
package pants is really good the only
negative thing I can really say about
packs is there was too much switching
out of jokes is a great experience it
was it was fun playing you know they
especially there was a couple games that
really highlighted you know like I said
sacrifice redemption was a fun game that
I want to play there's a game called um
fell what does that get called fail seal
fell still it's pretty much good in hand
else which
I mean I didn't know that okay but uh
you know it's it's pretty much a Final
Fantasy Tactics and I'm not even talking
about like you know it was inspired by
it I'm talking like these people might
as well have just copied it yeah but I'm
okay with that because I'm tired of
people trying to copy it and doing a
horrible no no you shout out to the big
guy said I believe that was one seed
company they had some great games man
had bad he had the best game that was
there yeah once he had that Hamrick
shoutout to a Carlos maverick that was a
great wave ever that also once he had
ancestors legacy the RTS which was Xbox
one excellent hits and we had to close
cinematics king remember that one where
they got all up on the camera and he was
on doing the one two was real cinematic
man that one was definitely definitely a
stand-up do we lose King from it now
he's muted you go maybe come back but
the King we thought about one set this
stuff what do you feel about pax in
general as an event for you for your
first time the Paris until I can eat
three or just you know in general what
do you feel honestly say that when it
comes to what and we were media so when
it comes to the delves getting in
talking about that game and the movement
around the place it was a little bit
different from e3 the last day was very
reminiscent of what is indicative of the
new III experience all right um because
remember before e3 was shut off from the
public so now this is a public event um
the the venue is it is a robust venue as
big it's a big enough venue that you can
move around you could see stuff the
games that was on display is new games a
lot of little games the booths was set
up more like a Comicon type of field
opposed to e3 e3 there's a lot of big
set pieces
yeah this is a lot of bite-sized chunks
so if you've ever been to like a
comic-con and you know that they have
tons of little booths all around the
place is the same exact way as far as
selling merch and stuff like that it
goes along those same exact paths of
merch will be sold here and there um
what you have to realize is these devs
some of them the ones that we gave
t-shirts to were 100% into giving you
what the game was about how to control
with their game what their vision for
the company is and the passion that they
brought across was a very strong like
you felt it so those they got t-shirts
oh there's iron Lords worthy um you know
II think yes some devs that you know
felt like it was a chore for them to
beat it
no I'm not saying that all doves that
didn't get a t-shirt acted in that
manner some definitely you know I look
at it LOCOG me know like this dude's not
you know working hard as far as getting
this across because there's competition
on that floor everywhere you turn there
was fantastic games and I'm honestly I
can't tell you that we covered every
fantastic game there but for anybody to
say that this industry is in a downturn
or it's heading towards a crash they are
out of their mind there was a game that
law Cognito was playing with a piggy
game him and addict was playing it the
graphics was horrible hey well it was
absolutely horrible with these guys
having so much fun making a sandwich
with a pig like bacon blood will fly off
of them I was an amazement of little
game this is one game all rock I think
that's the one well it was the book
hammering bottom yes yo all right it's
black and white with red red red will
pop up on the screen with bad stuff is
going down it is V it looks cute it is
for the bloodiest game
I've ever seen all right it is and it's
so the visual feel of it the fun the
things that it's doing the changing
mechanics from first person the third
person to side-scroller it's worth it
and these gems are here so I know a lot
of times y'all y'all you'll go after the
big-ticket items but I'm going to tell
you there's a lot of indie games that
are coming once II had the show for me
oh yeah 1c deftly had a tremendous
impression like tremendous food and I
think is now the amount they hoping for
anybody who's not going shot to a game
in perspective last night yes we turned
around their entire spoot was filled
like every station and I played the
first game and turned around they done
cleared the entire boot so we could play
all their games yeah once he was very
accommodating and it had just
high-quality stuff and I'm saying you
said we had fell [ __ ] over there the
final test Final Fantasy Tactics tile
game you had Heinrich which what King
was talking about that
Connie thought it was gonna be some
cutesy adventure game with some QT
character and this thing turned out to
be the most visceral funniest game ever
with all these different mechanics and
at one point addict is like what
mechanic don't you have it like you have
action you have first-person shooting
and then he was like what you gotta have
a racing and guys oh yeah we have a
racing segment also I like ancestors
legacy because I know arm addicts a big
RTS guy handle war stuff like that and
one thing about arts yes that I dislike
is that RTS tends to always keep the
action far away and what good reason you
got all units you get all that stuff but
what they did which was really cool was
whenever your units would engage it
would go into this cinematic style
battle and you really sorted the
pillaging and I remember King they were
burning down houses it was called
what was it enough fight cam it was
cinematic cam something
we had a name for it yeah it was amazing
man shout to them I want to also shout
out for me um I got obviously you got
you seen the article guys please support
it in links in the description but it I
kind of like the ten top sleeper ones
but also let's give a shout out to the
big-name guys like you know game
designer also a level designer Luise
Yepez great guy man got a chance to sit
down and talk to those guys and schmooze
a little bit put on yeah man it was
really cool stated became looks
absolutely fantastic level of detail on
the characters different zombies King
was recorded me getting whooped by a
zombie I should have ran from he's a
character that you he made small on your
team but it was him
shout-out to the zombie with the red
eyes there was no me and I did a cog do
not mess with that zombie with the red
eyes from down the block
I said yo get in the car and get out of
there now I said which is that you
really have that sense of fear there's
certain things you cannot handle by
yourself so that's the cool thing he was
showing us some base building which was
also dope all the different mechanics
that had choosing your leader this it's
so deep with the RPG mechanics and then
also we got a chance to talk to him
later they're even given the I'll track
if you guys are ILP exclusive they're
giving you guys the option to allow
people into your group or reject people
that you find into your group and one
thing that uh shot the [ __ ] he
was saying was that um you know in a
future possible DLC those people that
you reject could come back
negan type situation
you have bad humans now right now not
just the zombie thing so you got that
you got the resources and you got this
infection blood plague ding they've got
all these new mechanics game looks
phenomenal very impressed in Lord addict
remember the shooting mechanics right
now impressed we were with the shooting
mechanics addicts they obviously lost
legs back ok so yeah man it was really
cool
all right dizzy so it doesn't let you
bring it to your own world no here's how
it works with the coop basically the way
it was explained to me Milo for bogey is
dizzy if you got your crew right and you
got your survivors you're bringing in
one of your guys from your world into my
world and he could get perma death so
you better be very careful about who you
bring into your into your friends world
you like don't be bringing your A plus
dude all the time he could be out there
you know I mean so that's definitely
something that you guys need to keep in
mind you know I'm saying and then also
the progression of leader type skills it
was like Lord and all this other stuff
going on and shout out to like I said
man Louise he's also a destiny guy so he
was talking with him but um yeah he's
also talked about how the scale of the
world is in comparison to part one so Y
este to the king definitely I mean the
cosine ILP Seal of Approval all the way
on that I want to also shout out ashen I
miss anything
yeah we're talking about state of the
cabin I'm talking about chocolate we're
just talking about how the the shooting
mechanics were how impressed we were
with that part the mechanics or so cuz I
just recently stopped playing I've been
thinking about streaming it but uh I
haven't really took that initiative yet
there were so good where I was just
playing the first one again I was
missing every shot because I was trying
to use those garbage mechanics yes it's
not the compared to like the first one
the first one had extreme circumstances
and it was being made you know it was
annoying his name it didn't even really
have a whole lot of budget behind it
you know it was great for what it was
yes absolutely and and what I liked
about it too King was like you saw every
bit of detail on a character if he had a
knife he had the gun here
everything was placed on your character
your level backpack
um saying like the amount of detail on
the cap made me break my subscription
yes yes because I I know I was getting a
game for free and game pass right but
after seeing the game is seeing how much
they completely changed a lot of things
got a do it and on top we get into four
days early I can't have it out there in
them streets man so that was that you
know since that's four we gotta have a
IOP stream man oh you already know
that's going down that is going down
half clear I've been waiting for that
game so long so shoutout to state of the
kay guys fantastic shoulders tremendous
love got a chance to really go behind
the scenes with game fantastic also
wanna shout out a couple names real
quick out of the big guys ashen you know
I'm saying my guy
Derek Bradley creative director he
really sat down with me and I'll be
honest like I know I'm gonna be a topic
too much at it cuz I know we gonna talk
about the souls effect but that one
really surprised the the cooperative
aspect and what I like a lot of these
guys are doing they really going
cinematic with the story tone and he
actually taught actually broke down like
the whole thing about like going
faceless like something I just don't got
no purpose he's like yeah this is
purposely done you know that kind of
thing he breaks down how to seamless
co-op and jump in co-op is that kind of
thing and then he's talking about like
the weapon progression that like
basically like you can continue to level
things up even if it's like your level 1
club from the very beginning but if you
had a passion for it you can continue to
do things with the progression in
reference to that so that really
impressed me shout that and then
shout-out to add a cold aim y'all
let me tell you man it's all did you see
the video we put up wait Alamein stuff
ya know king adequate talked about that
Cove a y'all which I felt yes I knew
about that game going in and then I saw
attic playing the game mm-hmm yes
this guy's got yo listen let me tell you
something about Eddie
this guy is underrated all right um I
want two squads to go to eat to be
honestly if this is my heart right here
I really want two squads to go three III
come on Lord Chi by two to go to III and
I really want um Lord sovereign there I
really want to see Laura Chi bites
reverses Lord addict when it comes to
these hard game right what Lord addict
jump into these games remember that game
sinner yes I've seen Lord addict jump
into these hard games these soul type
games without a beat like he was playing
it all his life yes
like he was playing it all his life it
is just this is this is I almost beat
that display for sinner on my it was my
first attempt on was beat that dude
until he like road like a gorg on all
the soda and killed me yeah you did you
think you had it you definitely had it
first of all for me like again talking
that your next topic but I'm losing not
to talk show cigar but that game the art
style it looks like an anime yo yo saw
when they say we play a core oh really
me with a fourth AI companion so we
didn't mention that to me it's over
that's that's what names day one for me
sounds like oh but you telling me I got
I can bring my micro help I got help
thing that the souls games have when
people can invade your game and stuff
like that that yeah but that's another I
almost beat that boss - I was really
disappointed with that one
yes so what inch away from dying and I
died like so how do you guys different
games is a faster the faster than boy
has it's really bad at her face I will
say the only game I've ever seen that
more fast-paced is neo Neos crazy fast
pace mm-hmm yeah man I was thoroughly
impressed and like I said I love the art
style I love everything about it like I
said the co-operative aspect was really
cherry on the top for me so just that
enemy it looked like Devil May Cry mixed
with Guyver mixed with you know they
just look crazy whoever's there our team
on fire Namco's got one shot up speaking
the Namco so caliber six y'all come on
okay and I said this is the pinnacle of
them working with that engine because
the first time they did it with Tekken
right so usually it goes the opposite
direction it goes Soul Calibur then Tech
ain't right and what I guess this has
shown you that Soul Calibur has
overtaken Tekken when it comes to
fighting preference because usually the
testing ground for any new engine from
Namco is so callable or whatever they
little titles is and Tekken is the top
top to high-priced ticket for them so
callable it's so complete so polished
every particle effect every cinematic
when you're fighting like it's like when
you give hard hits it's like it has a
reverb of the world
I couldn't pre-order the game fast
enough in my head I'm calculating like
how much money I'm spending walking
through this show
that's a definite purchase right and
that's a definite IOP challenge to other
podcasts out there y'all can get that
smoke like that smoke is available for
that small chelate mitsurugi
oh yeah got the white wolf in about a
year they got Goro from winter what
y'all gonna see channel 5 get busy when
it comes to that game um that's oh
that's our persona going out yeah
fantastic a chance for them calling
those guys and um be a good interview
with those guys refreshing I like that
they've added the Tekken 7 on power
crush mechanic those moves that kind of
like power through other moves to get
through then they also had those
cinematic joints I've got the name in
the maloca it knows the name where so
cinematic movie if you hit it you know
I'm saying they doing the bomb ballistic
cinematic on you would take a man
anything
so it's like a comeback mechanic Tekken
7 added it but the way they've done it
and I tried to press them you know I did
some ILP on the spot reporting because I
was pressing them as far as we know
Unreal Engine as far as the Xbox when X
how come the Tekken 7 4k enhancement is
not out there and basically you know he
didn't want to comment on it but I just
said look is so callable I had this
issue because right now we've seen this
one on on the PC 4k 60 max settings yada
yada yada
you know Xbox one X guys one of your
lives you know this power is it possible
so he says yeah but the footage it's
night and day and is this is no fanboy
stuff it's literally I mean it for case
XD on the other side like it's just what
it is you know saying you can see the
difference so shout out to them and then
on last thing I want to say obviously
another thing we notice off is our unity
engine is out here is sri chika
and it's been preferred yeah they
continue let me tell you yeah people had
to bend the knee to you because not only
is it showing showcasing its power its
showcasing its versatility we went to
rising star games they had decay logos
which is a standout me and addict love
that game remember 2k logos at it with
them on getting that uh broke down on
the bus though but you know what we're
talking about like probably a bill that
was probably a couple months old at that
time it's in development it's gonna
happen
absolutely but remember how good it
looked and however is yeah it had to
Zelda five but it also has some souls in
the bosses that just the art design like
it really stayed like yo decay and logos
is going to look like it might be some
and it's also being ported to the
Nintendo stage but uh we got that but
also they had is other racing game but
they had all Trailblazers they had uh
Rico you know I'm saying so these are
three different style what's up that was
another dev that was a hundred percent
the CEO was on site thanks
that was another death because the RICO
look like Max Payne the siege young and
a little border lands with dissociating
yeah it was that that was nuts the is
the framerate the speed of the kid was
crazy
I guess clear out a room um what was
that the other game that was the racing
game proud lazy swings they play on your
switch to swittel guys split guys let's
do with Meredith
oh yeah yeah the spoon guys in the cars
their squirtle cars then they had the
two other games shout out says that
those deaths that have multi-faceted
situations going on and they will work
in each station that was another dev -
I'm sorry it was so much so much the
truth and last two shots I want to give
for the one also one scum game scum is
out here baby
that looks phenomenal that that is we
got the video up the interview up with
the devil I hope each channel please
check that out the messenger y'all
kognito was please we got to literally
the game and he was like well this is
our next meeting of the quan gonna go
chill kids thank you for putting me on
to that crazy it is a minute I didn't
even know about the 16-bit time-travel
part article is up in the description
please check out that of a message of my
boy - Gary from sabotage games it's
coming this [ __ ] is gonna be crazy in
the last shout out this was my in the
cut joint failing y'all yo fainted this
was one Sunday King and I'm making my
rounds I'm trying to get a lot right we
were driving up to the Convention Center
and it turned into III right
it was the parking lot proudly houses
500 cars right it was full they were
telling us to go to another place and
I'm telling the LOCOG numerous we're
driving up dude look at the crowd this
doesn't make any sense now we thought it
would be Sunday they will be at church
it was the Lord there's nobody with the
Church in Boston or Sunday I'm like okay
you know how many interviews do you have
today
oh I have - so you're not a fan I'm like
you know what
- i'ma hit this role I'm gonna get on
this road this doesn't make any sense
um did not want to leave my dude there
to go to this convention center by
herself but he said - so I'm figuring
he's gonna bumper cuz we got there we
just pushing ups you know speed it up
you got that badge blue yo go move out
of the way
go go go media yeah Andy get off right
mm-hmm I'm watching him as I'm driving
this dude proceeds to see seven or eight
people living in Albany New York I'm
driving to Albany upset on fire because
I'm like yo dis you told me now yo it's
true that I gotta see but I'm gonna see
everybody else too and I'm gonna be
there to support you know cuz it's
nothing but so much fun as I'm moving
people out the way strong-arming them
out the way with the camera a lot of
stuff came came together last minute
like I said shout-out to um Cappy game
from below I got to sit down with no
apologies on the quality we're gonna
work on it you know obviously we would
not be live-streaming from the Boston
Convention Center ever again porque 60
in that yard a real way so on but yeah
shout to them got a chance to sit down
below fantastic game but the little game
I want to shout out was failing because
I'm logging like a [ __ ] will tell you
I'm making my rounds going between
interviews and one of the devs comes up
and I don't know who this person was and
they were like hey could you come by the
patch rising booth yada yada yada I'm
like you know I'm not so you know Laura
cog need not finish my appointment but
it's an animal word my feet were hurt
and I wanted to go home
I said let me go over to this family let
me see that was probably the highlight
of my Sunday like the game absolutely
amazing you know what it looks like um
soft it's a month cell-22 with the
attempted to go side-scrolling yeah
alright so it has that feel but with
better animations full RPG mechanics
story the whole bit towns and it looked
phenomenal and I'm like yo this game is
crazy so shout out to I want to give a
shout out Carlos Gonzales the game dev
my boy milk ogre vet you know I'm saying
from the narrative team they actually
it's coming to all platforms I believe
they have a Kickstarter jumping off
April 17 so in two days go to our tale
games.com the game this looks but it is
a lot of those games a lot of them are
smaller games right indie games like
that's where they get shine is okay so
those games can run on the switch was
not
like it was cool to kind of get them to
break protocol so Johnny centers Loki
told us it was coming up yes I like it
that's what kick somebody I hit you with
the Bobby is it coming out for the
switch listen to every last one you
gotta go back also a kick we got a shot
shot your boy from Fox and Forrest man
Oh Rupert Rupert yo he has everything
Rupert I know you watching I know for a
fact you know hit that like button
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wooper and Carlos Burton Carlos for the
most enthusiastic fantastic hey Carlos
man shout out to him for Heinrich that's
what his dad's mind fantastic he seemed
like one of the main des for that game
too and that's the thing so I'm about
PACs it's like a lot of these games you
seen you can see for the first time so
it's a different level of passion it
almost feels like you'll check out my
mixtape sign I'm nice you know oh yeah
[ __ ] surfers but it's just really cool
cuz you're getting to see these games
for the first time more infernal he
actually told me anything tell you you
gonna like facts a little bit a III I'm
telling you you know there's some
aspects to it that I really like see how
III goes you know this year obviously
was a different scenario we'll see how
ago
but yeah fantastic
fantastic show so you guys I know you
saw a lot a lot of stuff like in any
game like yeah any consensus game shows
on stuff like anything you felt really
stood above and beyond everything else
whoo would you which I'm a lefty on the
Lord's ass all right my game community I
thought was probably the game that you
must own right
that state of decay it's it it from from
a button-down standpoint of a game from
top to bottom
mm-hmm it was locked in like it was
locked in it like it checked every box I
checked your friends knew Chuck building
it checked uh you could be sneaky snow
from oh it had a day/night cycle they
check permits for those people to need
that hard our walls
Oh tells you it tells you like you could
play it casual or you can play it in
depth so it hit every criteria that I
asked for a game like it's other games
there that had certain aspects of those
criterias hit but didn't hit all of them
that's the only game price no price wise
to $49 you get to play it four days
early case move around that's $10 a day
and then you get there you up to ten
dollars for the free stuff mm-hmm-hmm
yeah you gon kick I mean he knew
yourself okay one second oh yeah it's
cool yeah addict what was your packs
game when the show narrowed down to one
it would probably be that fell game fell
see your Wow devs loving you right there
[Music]
um my two finalists is probably gonna
come down to see I don't want to count I
don't count anything because I already
know you know they like I so for me no
douche my said okay I already knew that
said go that was already on a list I was
I told the devs I clash I was
disappointed when it got delayed because
that was my that was my personal III
game for last year so when they let you
back on my art so for me I got a go cold
vain because I don't like Dark Souls
games you know saying shout out to kids
smooth chatter jazz 77 shout the Attic
we lose all their plan and I'm watching
him and I'm like I would play this you
know I'm saying like that that was the
difference like blood-borne Orla I'm not
into it I think it's just more of our
Spanish to solve like I don't like the
UM DD atmosphere like everything is very
drab the colors are dark like coal vein
is the opposite coal vein is bright it's
anime style it's it's just a very
colorful world on top not cute Edo but
like anime style you know I'm saying so
that is the selling then you don't coop
it's over you know I'm a sucker for
co-op so at that point I was like this
is day one so coal vein surprise me
in that sense I didn't think I would
like it like that
and graphically I can't wait to see how
that's gonna look on X that's gonna look
fun dude no you know I'm saying so
that's my journey right there so any
real question before we move on so we
asked Joe can't wait to be there next
year cuz I know that the whole aspect of
the whole thing about taxes has always
been more more friendly in terms of like
getting to talk to devs being like
they're really really amped to talk to
you where it's an e3 it just seems like
everybody's running back and forth doing
their own thing everybody's has shows
scheduled and his dad
when you walk up with the badge in the
eyeball so they look at your badge is
real quick it is real quick
Lord addict it is first we are
experienced I was happy that I was
different all I would on site a day one
to do oculus I got yeah he lives had a
whole party for me because I felt like I
was just over to be on oculus yeah
because you know LOCOG mural got the
email and it was like you know we have
the oculus party you know come through
they had no food but they had drinks
there right you ain't got even eat meat
but let me tell you something you gotta
have meat there for people that do eat
me it was non cypher not cypher with a
catered food situation they needed it
was like they were trying to kill you
all right but the games that they had on
display at the oculus joy it was so much
fun they had a lot of games there I
couldn't I can't go into these games
because there's a nondisclosure
agreement when it comes to a lot of
these games ohm and I will have to go
through my notes to tell you exactly
which games I can't talk about is
probably only two games I could talk
about and I know for a fact that his
paper planes which is great that's a
great game $19.99 it's probably on Steam
right now um but these games it was fun
it was a nice controlled environment it
felt like a Nintendo event it was very
sterile you know are very did you like
it or are you here or here or here all
right well all right so I got they're
not left got to Lord addict and he got
his first vr experience going it was a
crazy man
it's close crazy machines VR right it
was a little Timmy was standing on this
lining probably but standing on this
line for half an hour I get there we
show what would be here and we like we
play Fox and Friends first negates that
you want
in the Twitter his father could not see
anything but Blaine a little to me how
you're not media and your badge does not
do that Oh cuz we were like they just
move in people who come out to wake go
game like I was like but then you know
it easily went away with us so how much
fun that equals having come back they
let me come back we we made sure little
Timmy got his shine he got to the front
of the line
exactly questioner Atticus I never acts
addict this at the show I never acts as
a show on the Backstrom even got back to
the house you know VAX them anything
shoutouts a little Cognito for booking
the nice house with the bad tub with the
bathroom but you like that vo anything
yeah would usually a good sign you know
say her is a reason yeah
Oh like hey
I want to know because it looked like he
was having fun inside and I want to know
like yeah your real opinion of it
because for somebody that's never
touched it and that was your first time
I just my curiosity's kidding me it was
a good first experience for me oh nice
say that because I didn't want to hear
see like the entire rest of the packs
every time we come by something VR hey
won't you please ask them like when they
were like oh we have a VR game there I
thought that was deep I was okay I don't
have to play that knowledge because
there's you play everything I don't have
to play that nonsense if we could buy
you Kagura she was like put that put
that put that all skill oculus on I'm
why I looked at him with the most
serious face Blake I was he was like the
difficult gate cognitive bill we had
about VR we had a ball PC keep yo he
made that death garden video goal I
wrote him say like whatever death God I
had nothing I knew nothing about its PC
game we had an appointment with those
guys and yeah man people really want to
know so just to see you know added to
his thing people get an idea of what
this game is apparently it's a very high
anticipated game for people been waiting
for a long time before me yeah I mean I
just looked at it I said it looked cool
I added it to our tin ireri
and it actually blew up is one of our
biggest videos when I LP so shout out
the attic for that one man great PC
skills I'm saying but that's it I know
you did for everyone I killed they
should not be allowed to play games ever
again he was marking him it was marking
a man who's doing your thing man so we
gonna move on with a lot of topics to
finish it real quick so uh Lord addict
you are up talk about the effect of Dark
Souls what's going on we should tap it I
feel like there's been a lot of times in
gaming to where you know something's
been jump-started or you know I feel
like the strategies on right now is in
that diony where they need a jumpstart
you know that RTS your honor because
they don't really get a whole lot of
love especially on consoles on PC they
do have a lot more options but it's very
far in between I feel like a lot of
people don't give darksouls the credit
that it deserves because it not only did
it like start a new genre because I do
believe that Dark Souls honor is its own
genre because you know they built onto
it and before you know it like it went
from something a lot of people like to
selling millions of copies any kind of
like any kind of clone of Dark Soul does
very well look at blood-borne
blood-borne wouldn't be around if it
wasn't for how successful Demon Souls
and Dark Souls would thanks yeah so just
your question in reference to the effect
of it or just like like my question is
like do you think that Dark Souls had an
impact or do you think it a lot of
people don't think it created its own
genre they just expanded on genre that
was currently there but I couldn't tell
you like before Dark Souls and Demon's
so I couldn't tell you of another
franchise that did what it did yeah
guess often would let you jump in on
this I mean I think I think dark so
Demon Souls and Dark Souls I think what
it what happened was that they're the
ones that kind of caught on right
they're the ones that the design guys
caught on to them and they were like
wait a minute there's something really
special about these games like the way
the world folds in on itself and
everything is interconnected and they it
was just one of those things where
people hadn't seen something like that
and so long and then it was even though
those games were you know what kind of
rough around the edges when they came
out mom
they were polished enough where the
ideas that you know they got introduced
in like Kingsfield in Armored Core like
all of the old from software games all
of those ideas were refined enough in
this in Demon Souls and Dark Souls where
it finally caught on with everybody and
you know it just it just caught fire so
those games became like the zeitgeist
around it so yeah did today did they
come from a lineage of games that kind
of started at doing that doing that
stuff way before you
but they are I mean they do deserve
credit because they were the ones that
brought it to the mainstream you-you-you
know I knew that it was real real is
soda coffee soda I think and I think now
like when you look at like what cars
doing exactly like everything plays upon
that because people want more depth in
their fighting period like regardless of
well how you feel about how difficult
the game is and how you want to play
that those type of games or not I think
everybody wants more depth in their
fighting games they want they want that
you you're gonna need to block you're
gonna need to dodge you're gonna need to
marry you're gonna need to do all this
stuff it just it makes you more invested
in the game yes and and else oil it also
gives that sense of accomplishment but I
don't think ok let me let me say there's
been difficult games before this right
but the perspective that they took the
game in is the ratio of the character to
the screen right they give you enough
field of the screen to show you how you
can move left the right back or forward
right so this way you're moving in
omnidirectional plane and attacking the
character so you can you can attack the
character from left right and rear when
they lunge at you move to the side
this game is those games are so damn
hard for me that werewolf in the
beginning somebody told me about the
werewolf or the
getting was killing them uh of the blood
boiling in playing blood-borne right
when you first start the game I never
yeah I never knew that you could run out
and leave him okay so I can go back and
play my game cuz I have blood-borne and
I brought it because I'm a fan of
exclusive IPs if your system has these
exclusive ip's I'm gonna purchase now
when they did the Dark Souls thing it
didn't really talk to me
I played Kingsville before I don't view
them as the same type of game alright I
don't view them as that I view these
games this hack and slash black and
punch type of games where you use our
potions to heal yourself every time you
get bust up side your head um but when
I'm watching at it and this is the turn
for me that I saw at PAX there adding to
it yeah it is a sub-genre now then it
turned into a main genre then they're
taking things to find out how we can
mainstream this very difficult niche gem
yes yes that's what I'm seeing and in
that that cold vein yeah it's probably
the game I think that's in the direction
of getting that part right all right I
need help alright yeah if I can have two
people with me let me grab my alright so
I think coal vein is going to show you
how we can get this to the mainstream
audience because these games are selling
on their own but they wanted to tell
Zelda numbers right right
and I think coal vein will probably be
that game that starts that that the
precipitation of all the bringing our
water in to
that the downpour of this game making
the to the main stage big-time big-time
real quick I want to shout out October
we got some breaking news
looks like star field has a high chance
of being announced at Bethesda XIII 2018
showcase and releasing this all so a lot
of put the Elder Scroll rumors to rest
and it looks like star field man looks
like they're gonna jump into the you
know that the frontier in space which I
feel about that but that's done showcase
good Mass Effect massive pay they got a
shot bed we all know Andromeda you know
fell on its face a little bit so uh
we're gonna see what do you feel about
that a king and kings not about it you
don't want Bethesda in space pretty much
with the I agree with Kings point as far
as you know the genre as far as consoles
effect I think that um I think it's a
winning formula I mean just to
incorporate it into your game make
bosses challenging you don't add a
little bit of depth to the game you see
the wave and start to create what was
that game o matic sinners redemption I
think it'd yes and a sacrifice we seen
coal vein has we seen ashen now the
genre is picking up shouted dizzy in the
chat can you know I'm saying you know a
shot did he like he made that's the the
copies are analogy it's the souls it's
the battle royal you know say like this
is the new wave now so I think we're
gonna see baby I don't want y'all think
I'll be single in anybody out it's just
I look inside to chat sometimes I look
over nobody asked you really don't look
at it
I see cow and I see people and I'm just
let yourself what's going on everybody
you understand so you know Ram what's up
you know I wanted to tell you anyway I
wanted to hit you up and let you know
that I've been loving your videos lately
yeah rants my fire right now he's been
killed a shot - Cal - man killed it with
the bins in the podcast last night so
yeah that's pretty much what it is I
think addict is right I think the souls
effect is definitely definitely going on
in the industry right now we're gonna
see more of it and like you said we
already co-signed code vein and that has
an implement of it so uh we're gonna
we're gonna see so lord King you got
some mid generation maybe ps5 what's
going on all right so everybody is
talking about it's just PS five and is
it gonna be the the end-all be-all you
know kissing state they need it to be
done okay all right every time it's
gonna come out
you got a beat the new system is the
latest the greatest you everybody's
talking about the PlayStation 5 right um
rightly so you know these spec leaks
that's out here are they real are they
fake you know most of the time some of
the stuff is real a rise in seven chip
maybe all the hybrid rice and chip
that's inside the system okay great
custom ap API in there and custom GPU
inside okay of course we know the
surface common I'm backward-compatible
is not true I don't believe so I believe
that is that diametrically opposed to
their philosophy in that company all
right
they keep AMD then I don't I don't they
have been always known to squeeze the
dial out so I don't think that and I
don't think it starts now they didn't
lose they've dealt winning by not giving
you back a path they
told you to your face nobody cares about
that and they showing you like that I'm
winning I told you so shut up why would
they go back on it it doesn't make any
sense that's what you're saying with the
doll in time with the guy Kai and things
of that nature like to streaming yeah
they're gonna go they're gonna double
down on what they're doing they talking
about VR VR has probably made them some
pretty large chunk of change
and they're seeing it going in that
direction because there was a lot of VR
games there so it being baked into the
system I believe so but my question is
not even about the system we know what
the system is inevitable right all that
you know systems are dying that crap is
a lie all right it's a fallacy but
they're talking about this year next
year hmm
in my opinion if they come out so early
after launching on other $500 system
$400 $475 system
and that's the port in it all the way
through Tate's death do they go the way
of the 32x legacy the Tory Jaguar or
their overstepping their bounds or is
this hubris coming into a company who
has so 70 something million in a blink
of an eye hmm and do they feel if you'll
buy anything or you're their fool to
launch a system right so closely after
they just for this drop in the pro my
adocus off one this jumpy jumpy well I
mean in terms of the hubris like like we
said in the past if conspiracy theories
are true it's their turn to mess up
their turn to snatch defeat from the
jaws of victory I mean who knows
anything could happen
um but in terms of like the the system
coming out so soon after pro-pro came
out 2016 like I don't see this system
coming out any earlier than 2020 I just
it doesn't make any sense to me that
they would they have no reason to rush
the system out right they want to make
the system as powerful as possible while
keeping the price lower I don't I think
they're thinking would be let's try to
give the most powerful system we can
give them a $400 which is gonna be tough
right I think Microsoft with the with
the success they've had with the X I
think they're willing to give you a $500
system and not worry too much about the
blowback they'd get about you know about
price point and stuff like that um so I
think you know they may try to hold out
as long as they possibly can I mean with
this with the setup day that's being
sort of leaked you know it's in eight
cores and CPU they're talking about an
avi GPU that that has been sort of I
guess benchmarked to sort of mirror 1080
TI performance performance so so you're
looking at a system that can guarantee
you 1080p 60 and hopefully guarantee you
4k 60 with that you know like this place
all we have to admit the issues right
now just is really CPU I mean it
everything is seeping around
that's what's preventing I mean we've
had the whole destiny Fiasco with the
pro and the ex and the reasons why
destiny to couldn't do what it did on PC
so that has to be a focus the question I
heard they have I have for you based on
what Kings done now on King seems like
let's talk about time frame right shout
out to the chair shot the brad.leah and
okay
it's forest-like 2019 versus 2020 where
you at with that as far as that time
frame of when they should release I
think the switch has shown that you
don't have to release a console in
November I think you can release it
anytime early in the year so I see two
scenarios
I see you know the traditional scenario
would be announced early 2020 launched
late 2020 or announced PSX late 2019 and
release first quarter 2020 yeah the way
it's a 2020 release for me is this
depends whether it's early in the year
late in the year
right yeah I think it'd be a mistake man
I think it'd be sick to drop in 2019 I
just don't you know my gut says they can
announce I can see that maybe announcing
you know I'm saying that in that respect
but on again they've had they got this
tremendous moment right they are
crushing it right now you know for a
system sale the you know first party is
in spectacular space we're getting to
the God of War topic soon you know
saying so it's just like they're killing
it so at this point you know there's no
rush to jump out now the next question I
have and i'ma bring this to a dick if
you still around X not sleeping okay is
that um I need to know when they decide
to launch this ps5 because it's
inevitable like King Zane is inevitable
what does Microsoft do do they
now wait for ps5 to have a here in the
market or time in the market to
themselves I think that will be a
mistake
or do they want day in gate or in year
at the same time attic what do you feel
about that
they'd have to launch neither the day
over or before like right now it'd be
different if they were the market leader
and they had all the ice going into next
generation like so recover from that
year all right would be harder but they
could recover from that year right now
what we're looking at besides you eatin
stuff we're just looking at if they did
that what would happen one thing is do
you think people would wait a year for
the next Xbox console would be different
if they can't afford that
if Xbox have been dropping heat the last
couple years
they were just down because of the
council of because you know they they
they love to the fifth they left the
Gator late that'd be one thing but we're
not really haven't left this generation
I mean Xbox hasn't let the generation
yet we've good
well good content let's be real here
like
decay is the first decent-looking game
they've had in a minute mm-hmm
and you know see it these super guards
how you feel about see these uh you know
it did get a lot of negative publicity
you want that publicity where the out
were the positive heavily outweighs the
negative that's the kind of games they
would need to be able to wait a year
after launch and they don't have it yeah
I mean no and Phil said it I mean it you
don't really hear Phil's make statements
like this a lot but he said he's like
Xbox fans deserve better first party
support and specifically in response to
what people have been saying about God
of War
he says deserved this shout out child
guarantees for the video obviously that
the streets went on fire I mean if you
saw Brian McCaffrey's tweet I don't know
if anybody got you to see it and on you
know he's pretty much saying since the
God of War thing Xbox fans have been
clamoring for a first-party masterpiece
exclusive like that and you know
basically he didn't even out direct it
at a Phil Phil actually just responded
he was just like you know how long do
you think you know these guys will come
and basically basically my McAfee saying
is like look that thing kind of took
about 10 years to ps3 error for them to
develop that level of quality of a game
that came out eventually in this
generation and that it would take
Microsoft the same amount of time which
is probably stuff is probably being
cooked up or it's in the works now that
most lazy what'd he say most likely
we're not getting that this generation
he's in so the reality is those kind of
masters games that done really good you
know not even really good commercially
for sale like games like rise they
really need to try to get that because
that has a name now because they need to
buy cuphead mmm-hmm because I feel like
cuphead regardless it's not going
anywhere
like they lock them they're not anyway
people want to be excited about new IP I
mean it's it's not the same impact to
get a ten out of ten halo anymore they
need to still that same way that these
dudes stole Dark Souls they need to do
blood-borne they need to do Gears of War
blood-borne just the same way I'm about
to go in all this stuff that's coming up
next let's leave this bleeding sent to
your topic so yeah obviously we know
what's going on with karna war right now
see the reviews it's going crazy out
here you know I'm saying and rightfully
so you know I'm saying shut up boy lord
Jacobus out there doing the mocap you
insane
Kolby koryagin say everything is work
hard for it absolutely he's a true gamer
he's a true game definitely shot him out
so it's like we seen what's going on we
seen that effect and I just gonna jump
in on it because me personally we just
got a call a spade a spade I just don't
think this generation even if those
titles are cooking up from Microsoft and
Phil has I hope you surprised me it
proves me wrong this year but I don't
think those titles will be ready for
this generation let's just call this
generation what it is this is the L you
know Sam this is now you got a Riku it's
the equivalent or relative thing yeah
it's like you got this one artist you
know and he's going gold every time then
you got Drake is drink that's just what
it is those Meek Mill right now I'm just
saying they just they're gold not an L
finance me they're not in shambles I'm
just talking about from a competitive
standpoint for us this generation this
is L all I'm saying is for next gen they
can now Rican we tool reload you're
cooking up the studio's fill they've got
the hardware down they've got the
services down you
got the game do they killing you too big
bill copyright but it's like to me I
think those next time like a fee more
all the stuff in cooking because the
narrative that people are doing right
now this is just a scrap this is what
happens when you do to do down this is
why this is the app this is what happens
when you smash somebody mouthing damn
what Xbox Dave with 360 they beat that
PlayStation to a bloody Pope you know it
I know it
there was the meet years of situation no
other sudden they want to reinvent
herself no no no what they did was
because it wasn't buying no games last
generation because they all had was the
last bus they came back PlayStation 4
come out we all buying it they all got
together and they sat in the corner and
they waited for the launch right they
waited they waited and when the launch
happened every time I play station was
up for sale they purchased it listen you
ask box hands who got your hair beaten
because right now the ring-a-ding-ding
is going down right not work them and
really ding ding is going down right now
right now you own that one man you're
looking up and he's about the curb stomp
you all right this is what's happening
right now
save your money date and date you'll
feel do not let the PlayStation get a
second out that door there 5 get out
that door Nicky day and day yeah the
Xbox comes out the same day with the
same specs of great aspects I don't care
I do it you make sure you do it I'm down
with you having the same specs it can't
be the same specs in halo 4 halo I think
that's the biggest thing they could they
can even afford to come out even weaker
next gen what they can't do is they
can't afford to come out with being more
having no real first party titles launch
and having a weaker system altogether
they can't wallet three well I think
from the Navi standpoint I think they've
learned their lesson as far as the
hallway we feel that they've gotten that
down the ex is a fantastic piece of all
we can't knock that you'll see at the
end of the day it's gotta be that those
games they've been working on have to be
available for this next-gen system and
like King said the system has to come
out the same year as pf5 if they cannot
afford to let Sony be in the market a
year earlier in my opinion based on the
state of things even though 40 millions
not NL I'm just saying in terms of
competitive market leader relevance they
will get hammered
if they wait it won't even be relevant
at that point when you get that VR baked
in your brain first of all I got to be
your unbaked I got the UM big deal
section same in I don't think a new IP
is good enough like they got a handle
recognizable I think it has to be new IP
stuff grease let's be real 360 the
reason why 360 did we did is we all know
whether we saw it at mad world trailer
remember you saw gears for the forever
seen anything like that before I was
like okay the message can't be flung
about TVs and all this other crap you
know we have a clear vision now to be
honest with you and he has got the
narrative down he's got the power aspect
down
he's been smart enough about taking away
certain things and allowing things to
happen right and a real boss builds
bridges not walls okay
and when gears
God of War had his oculus any time there
PlayStation has got any form of
alkaloids he has extended his olive
branch to the point of yo
congratulations on that
you know um stop all the fanboy
narrative that part has to be moved to
the side because it's about games that's
what we're about win ballgames all right
now I'm getting it also I'm a bag or
switch I got a switch I could back on it
alright um I'm back on Xbox to see your
thieves if you buy yourself you see
mm-hmm all right you know I mean y'all
may think that all I play is plug G
because I'm going with monkey punch and
these dudes we be getting in it's just
so much fun I'm just with the team's
just so much fun but you have to
understand that is going to take more
than what they were giving at the
beginning of dis generation which was
uncertainty under the powered and
forcing you to get a Kinect
there's no connect there there's no
uncertainty and I don't believe that we
will be under power and I say we because
my blood is green because my team is on
the side let my team go over the
PlayStation I'll be saying we over there
you know boss Moses and he said Phil
needs us to give us the cracking body
DLC you see at the end is cuming mark
saw has two I think they're in position
I do I do think that they will not make
that mistake and like Phil's tweet was
saying which was kind of like look
services took time you know the hallway
it took time I'm saying first it's gonna
take time so when I hear stuff like that
i big i brace myself to say okay i'm i'm
expecting to see more things
probably for the future this easy as
opposed to oh this is gonna be right now
I don't expect to see fable release this
year you know I mean a lot of this stuff
that I think that's going to be
announced and even on a Playstation side
like shower to the chat you know go see
Tsushima last a lot of this stuff I
think it's will be PlayStation 5 stuff
that's just my opinion you know I feel
that a lot of this that we are now
prepping ourselves for the next major
only the only game that might come out
for this gen that Ghost the one for
Sucker Punch that's all I don't even
know no way why suppose to comes out for
this I would think but I see I would
think I would think they they have days
gone come out and separated completely
from the Last of Us 2 and Tsushima and
Last of Us 2 I forgot about is gone
yeah get get pushed out more towards the
PSI I I do both come off a ps4 but I
think those across gen cross-platform
games like I think imagine a PS 5
launching with best of us to and go
through sushi like mmm yes I started
sober he said me saying he thinks last
was is still more likely for ps4 he
still thinks it's coming yeah loosely
wrap this thing up we got last time
again obviously we'll just brace do this
real quick real quick I didn't say this
I don't addict put up a great video
talking about like games that get
perfect turns and stuff like that and
that's a great video and I and I like
his perspective on it
I don't think games there's a button
that says oh my feeling is this
I don't number number reviews man like I
rather somebody say like you're a gamer
how they do were they talk about the
game they talk with us like what they
don't like at the end of like we
recommend this game we highly recommend
this game remember reviews man that's so
subjective yeah I don't think owned up
with it it gets all crazy mom just but
but looking at the reviews like if you
look at Metacritic it's sitting at 95
right now
has 27 100 reviews
insane 27 so I mean from that whether
you hate whether you love whatever you
can glean that most people think the
game is a quality game and you should
play it right right um and it's my
feeling is this look if you hatin if
you're just hating then you don't want
to see that
pre-ordered listen I will be playing my
playstation listen I got a lot of games
for playstation I really want to get
down to play well my fun friends is OB
on Xbox one I'm gonna use the app the
Xbox has that you can be in-game chat on
this side when they allow us to be in
cross chat on the same systems and all
that stuff
s Columbia a wonderful day when that day
when those doors open up and we want you
to add me
that's right baby what'd you say I mean
I agreed listen I'm with yourself got a
wallet like his Mina here I told addict
I told them I told them they they out
here doing the last of us and asking
formally addict was
in and I say yo I like the direction you
don't say I like the direction that I
like that cinematic approach and I
remember seeing the video now her boy
and I was in and I was like I already
know what's going down so I knew I was
gonna sell did I think it was gonna get
this type of critical response
no but I'm there day and date and I'm
just like you soft like I don't get
caught up with the hyperbole of tense
now say it's the same thing this reminds
me of one Zelda came up right now and
I'm gonna hard shoes critic I'm the guy
that's gonna go against the grain when
everybody else is sweating it you know
so I'm gonna see what it is
so when I do that Zelda when I was
completely engrossed so now I gotta see
if this really you know I'm saying hey I
don't to me the number means nothing I
think the thing that we gotta be careful
right now when I'm seeing out here in
these gaming streets is that shout out
to some of my Sony crew I love y'all but
it's like I've noticing a lot of throw
it in the face of the Xbox dudes there
you notice that like your ammo type
console you have everything it doesn't
matter even if you're not enjoy that I
want to smoke but now Real Talk is
everybody just enjoy the game and have
fun don't be done in nobody face give
you out there and you hate
and you and me let's say you're an Xbox
guy and you just let go
eggs because at the end of the day let's
keep it a buck a lot of people in all
these console generations make a choice
you bet on a horse yeah
which one do I think is gonna be their
date man we're gonna play this thing
attic real quick so we can move on its
off real quick three more about God War
[Music]
we got the last time not really I've
played it I can't really like I'm not
gonna like have an educated guess on
other people's educated guesses on rye
so you like me you like yo I'm not
paying attention to the to the stuff
until you play I'm assuming fact yeah
Cal said you'd work I would move away
breeze through um just be the final time
we get out of here all right inside Xbox
went down yeah we all know the show
anybody got a chance to catch it but
I'll just recap real quickly obviously a
ton of news was announced we've got back
with compatibility uh bill Stillwell man
that's my guy he was out there and he
had
your salute bills there well I mean I
don't know what type of sorcery y'all
working over their head these games
looking how these games are looking but
man I mean Red Dead Redemption I fired
it up this morning in 4k absolutely
astok
they had announced a couple of xbox360
more Xbox and his titles and then of
course the Megaton was the OG xbox games
so obviously you know we had to show and
that's kind of stuff going on so two
things I wanted minutes of launch one
you know about the backward
compatibility stuff how do we feel about
it and obviously there's a narrative
going on right now maybe Microsoft was
focusing a little bit too much on that
so that was the first thing and then the
second thing is obviously fan fest was
announced and we all know how we feel
about fan fest a lot of the lords have
gone to e3 because of fan fest we have a
new system now you know as far as how
that saw getting out there how you get
access to it so let's start with Lord
adding let's get lost sleep woken up you
know what do you feel about backward
compatibility and then what did you feel
about the arm fan fest new set up nor
addict but I really it's interesting how
they're deciding to do the fan fest now
do you agree with it as composed to the
old system like because what we have now
we got like what is it a four to five
hundred of the people will get to chance
to go 400 people will get a chance to go
to Fan Fest which is the whole shebang
right you get in the conference you're
getting the execs the Wine and Dine all
the events and then there's gonna be a
thousand people who get a chance to
actually go to the briefing I'm
Microsoft griefing only so what do you
feel about that no system I think I
actually call that no order IOP the
reason that they're upgrading the venue
like that is has something to do a fan
fest and then they say they're letting a
thousand people in the conference there
is no coincidence in that so and I was
gonna say about backward compatibility
is a shout-out to gamer perspective last
night I was on this show shout undead
Eric Jackson raid virus
the crew no I'm saying we was on the
show last night so my question is like a
lot of people say look when they watched
inside Xbox that the focus on
backward-compatible and I'm saying that
you know is this now Microsoft's new
joint because they don't got game light
up what cuz ain't got games alright so
what all right so what is back pack you
wanted to play Red Dead right I see Red
Dead red they look fantastic
can you play red there's someplace else
better than this no so why would we
champion something like that listen man
I'm not opposed to more games they're
talking about more games more giving you
value for games that you haven't worn
and you can't play anymore so what is
the problem here like what is the
controversy when they say yo your joint
can do more in your car right now and
you can go over water one thing what
about that people say that I don't want
to play old games and it because because
Microsoft they they feel that maybe they
don't have something to show or do you
feel it that people are being too hard
on Microsoft won't because it's an
inside Xbox show and that they're not
really gonna announce that kind of stuff
you know what I'm sick of tired of I'm
sick of tired of everything that every
everything that Microsoft do somebody
would have some negative to say about it
everything they can go your cancer
tomorrow but they would acute cancer
though but they didn't kill polio you
know you don't want them to win for
whatever your problem is and I'm gonna
tell you right now
40 million 50 million is not a loss um
taking the power narrative from your
behind it's not a loss fixing that the
division is not a loss giving you new
IPs when they
it wasn't there's no new eyepiece I
don't care what you say steer thieves is
a game and it's good and it's fun and
it's dead pump G is a game that's in
development and it's fun and it's dance
so five million five million all right
so listen to this man I'm sick and tired
of all the anything Microsoft does it's
a problem but if any other company does
the same exact thing it's no I got a
question
I'm so glad you said it's because that's
gonna tie into the fourth question for
the show which is the argument to that
is people say well what I can't be
critical are you saying why ma'am or for
from your system alright I'm gonna give
you this well my grandmama used to told
me god rest her soul
mmm everybody has a butthole nobody
needs to hear it everybody you know
nobody needs to hear your father you
don't have nothing good to say don't say
nothing at all what what what is
understood doesn't need to be said God
of War is a great game god bless good
luck mm-hmm is it a split off from
Microsoft back oh did you kill workforce
war guard war no you didn't game still
playing I'll be playing my xbox the next
day all right I'm gonna be playing my
god war the next day why can't you just
enjoy games and just overlook whatever
problems that other people have because
y'all can't get online but do you hear
Microsoft screaming at everyday the just
system is down and your money is being
compromised because you don't know if a
dude in Dubai has your credit at the end
of the day I hear what you're going King
I just want to give I want to be dead
play devil's advocate and give those
people a voice which is you know they
feel that hey you know you guys a damage
control that you know you guys need to
demand more from X but because of the
success of places because of what's
going on with God well because you know
we see these announcements from
Microsoft that I don't say it's all
focused on backward compatibility but
you know there's been lately right
so people are saying like well you need
to consistently demand more and I'm just
gonna go into the poll question because
literally I'm dying
go for it if somebody asks you a
question
and you answer it honestly right they
asked you to question how is that damage
controlling when you're answering a
question that has been asked to you
facts you don't agree with their opinion
then it turns into damage control that
is they want you to be a sheep and
beehive mine and followed their opinion
here's a quiz all if your favorite
console the company routinely
disappoints you by the decisions or the
lack of moves that it makes is it okay
and this is the key word to consistently
demand more from said console and
company the answers are a yes keep
demanding better never settle for the
status quo be know you are beating a
dead horse if you're that bad get rid of
it on both your favorite and competition
problem solved or D I don't have that
problem
my council ever discipline Jack because
he definitely helped me inspire that
this question and on you know if this is
one that's really hot right now is
gaming streets you know as far as what
everybody's feeling and stuff like that
pertaining to Microsoft and other things
so uh yeah this we're gonna hit the poor
hard they got to remember man like you
guys did a month and a half away two
months away from e3 they're not gonna
drop hot fire on Xbox what you're gonna
get oh yeah the expectations are too
high for some people who expect the
announcements exactly because you're
getting III then you're gonna get you
know Gamescom you're gonna get all these
other place they have stuff that goes
into holding Microsoft at a higher
standard than you do anybody else
because my Nintendo dropped a little
direct nobody's altar like the thing
about Nintendo is a Nintendo you already
know that that's just
be the way they do it so whether they do
it now or they do it at e3 you're gonna
get a direct at e3 then you're gonna get
treehouse live where they're gonna play
that stuff live you're not really gonna
get big announcements live he's holding
somebody else to a difference what is
the PlayStation shoulder comes out every
month stuff just in their Twitter feed
like they'll announce something like
this at the end of the day we are happy
that inside Xbox exists let's just call
it for what it this is something they
needed to do now again for the damage
control comments all that stuff I get it
if you're not happy with what's being
said or what's going on in the direction
then this how I feel it's okay to sit in
demand more from your platform in your
console all I'm saying is there comes a
point where if you keep somebody keeps
disappointing you right if someone if
you have a company or product and I'm
just tired of the direction it's okay to
go to another direction it's okay to say
you're gonna mean look they're not doing
it for me right now you know I'm saying
I'm over here it's okay I don't feel
well and I got a different cogs I'll see
you in the chat can you definitely spy
this question you got some reach over
some I don't feel that's necessarily a
bad thing like to say look they're not
doing it for you then hey maybe you need
to make a decision and get rid of it
doesn't mean that you can't speak up all
you're not for changing and getting the
company to change to your directive but
it's the same thing with us as me and
destiny right now right you know I'm
crazy I'm like what the hell is it but I
have a choice do I stay here and hope it
gets improved or I say hey you know what
division 2 is coming you're there you
know what such a such game we all have
that choice they don't think either one
is wrong you know I'm saying that that's
where I'm at with it just I see this a
lot going on right now where people who
love Xbox still are being attacked for
damage controlling and making excuses
and then I'm seeing the opposite side
with people who say that Xbox is not
doing enough then it's like okay then if
you're so dissatisfied right yeah and
they're not listening let's you say
they're consistently not listening to
what you as a game or what it's okay to
go to the other side man just have
everything and weight to the weight to
the other side get the act together to
be disappointed when you have everything
because we have something to go a side
piece to go we gonna wrap this dig up
back yes Lord addict in the sleep
chamber we gotta wake up what am I going
to as far as if something keeps
disappointing you what do you do he's
disappointed that's the whole thing he
has he has the best of both worlds he's
been on that PlayStation he's playing
his xbox mmm and it's for a grapple I'm
Christmas actually what do you what do
you feel about what's going on as far as
people being upset in saying it you know
that people need to demand more from
Xbox or you know also just damage
controlling I feel like people take this
conscious stuff a little bit too far on
both sides I feel like people want to
they're so obsessed with justifying the
brand that they chose they're so
obsessed with calling fraud ow for not
saying stuff and I'm just like I just
don't understand like you know like who
cares how someone feels about it like
who are you to judge another person how
they feel about a call team
and it just seems like you know you got
a lot of people that don't even play
these consoles like mad people and I'm
like you don't play it's like why does
it bother you well you know I think I
know what it is and i'ma call it for
what I call it it bothers them because
these people because majority of them
love Xbox they love it so much it was
like when you see when you see something
that it's like remember like D remember
like Roy Roy Jones mommy right you'll
see but if you keep getting knocked out
foot under the rope with his legs
crossed every time people have moved on
right my thing is if you're happy with
the chick you wit start worried about
the chick you left don't let them say
they still have don't look through the
window be happy with the person you
chose the system you chose the thing
that you decided to get that you wanted
to make your thing that you put out
there I'm PlayStation now this day
PlayStation now I'm switch now let's
stay switch now don't look over somebody
else like to be fair mat Xbox dudes did
buy ps4 and that's what I'm saying you
can buy the ps4 it's ok is it
you didn't have to sign a disclosure
that you can only buy one Colin so these
guys are locked in attic that's the
thing a lot of these guys
but I think there's some people that
legitly have every console and they
still do you know absolutely absolutely
it is just like I said people just need
to let people enjoy we go please rock
that pole I'm very curious where I'll be
58 oh I'm very curious please rock that
Jay let's get these out rolls popping
Lord addict no longer lost sleep back in
the tension wicked me on blood one cuz I
still got one boss left to kill no doubt
baby didn't go get in the conquer kid
you know like when you take his health
halfway lose his legs and he just drags
himself across the screen and he leaves
like a trail of blood that's on fire
every time he hits his hand on the
ground a giant burst of fire comes in
I'm like yeah the moment I fought him
one time you got to that stage I was
like I hope he's in an hour I can't
dance I had to figure this out let me
let me let it rest for a little bit so
you got there seems going on I see you
got it you guys gonna be doing any other
soul types games as well you look at me
and kid are gonna be playing ash that's
gonna be dope shout-out to the cow for a
coming into my stream he saw me
literally beat the last boss in the
expansion but thank God he joined the
one stream that I beat him he joined the
one attempt that I've either nice to Cal
the chatter shout the rare everybody
chat bribe a chat was absolutely Lord
solve what can find people finds good to
be back with you back in the round
have the Brethren back yeah man just
look up next week obviously we're all
gonna have our impressions of God of War
next week
I will be playing from hopefully Tuesday
so nice I may just unplug my even a big
sovereign lord being sovereign PSN Xbox
Live North stop IOP yeah because you're
not gonna see me look go go get these
aisle
[Laughter]
I'm gettin Lord kids smooth show me how
to stream on all three at one time BAM
let's go up I'm gonna be screaming their
cradles that's done go down day one I'm
gonna put that up there so I can y'all
can see me play that my [ __ ] cameras
up so y'all gonna see me play that game
also the shirts does the store up is
sick I'm sick right now no I've been
working hard
I'm gonna finish up this week so that
merch to be there those shirts is uh oh
then the new shirts reclaim yours hit me
up he knows there's gonna be seven
colorways I'm gonna give you the
pre-order for those those are the e3
shirts okay those are the pre-order for
that um these shirts right now are $25
shipping is included
we have limited supply get the rest of
them now because once they are printed
the pack church um you see that that
that patch after that that's it no next
one's will be three shirts and those are
limited editions as well so I'm coming
mad colorways get at me and listen this
gives video quality to all of the Lords
all right now I'm just saying that you
know um cuz we have to do a little bit
more for Laurel kognito look I need to
need extra stuff for his join to go for
the video quality Lord sovereign get him
a camera know that get him up in there
you know I'm saying and um
Lord addict the same thing we want to
bring you more greater things to the
podcast and start taking up to the next
level for you guys so join me because I
enjoy playing games at all cuz I play
games with most y'all and I'll be honest
with you
so um thank you for the support we
really appreciate everything in this
action see that money turned around and
went right back into investing into you
guys absolutely shut up not everybody
supporting aisle p and and the shirts
man we see in the love shouted is
everybody who put his shirt up and
tweeted it like it really it felt good
just to see the support and love from
everybody and like i said we gonna get
the packs thing you know i'm saying we
got that that was the first taste of it
III we go level up crazy we got some
cool things planned for that you know
I'm saying definitely like like King was
saying like everything definitely gets
reinvested back into the ILP
should have a fun show next Sunday us
maybe a special guest stay tuned we're
trying to work on some things but um
yeah
you gotta talk about the God of War
that's gonna be fun so again please
subscribe hit that like all that good
stuff
audio and hauless time stands to be up
later tonight also flashpoint 11 woody
pontus went up talked about the Gulf at
all the new updates and all that you
know ed Torres says that day knows
though like that day toes the kid got
brought up yeah man so everybody
everybody enjoy this Sunday I see the
close-up one thing those because you
don't see shy right now we all know that
we're not we know it still love baby we
still love oh you do it too much with
infinity going Finity war two weeks
y'all we will catch you the daddy he let
that man keep those gems in his all